[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage andrew and courtney are
with us hey guys how are you hey good
how are you welcome where do you guys
live we're from madisonville kentucky ah
okay up in the hopkinsville area welcome
to nashville and here to do a debt free
scream how much have you paid off sixty
two thousand four hundred and forty
seven dollars and sixteen cents i love
it not that we're counting
how long did it take you 22 and a half
months good for you and your range of
income during that time
from about 85 down a little bit and then
back up to about 95. cool what do y'all
do for a living
i'm in manufacturing i work for a ge
i
started out working for the orthodontist
in our town and then i switched to the
board of education ah okay and was that
a good raise
it was not
it took a lot of prayer and talk
we did a pros and cons list and
it was a
pay decrease but we
adjusted our
our um
that was when it went down a little bit
yes and then it came back up yes okay
good yes sir very good good for you guys
what kind of debt was the 62 000
uh it's mostly uh there's a few credit
cards a couple of uh personal loans a
couple 401k loans okay all right what
were the 401k loans for what'd you buy
uh it a lot of our debt stemmed from uh
a gambling addiction i had
um so that's uh
you know that's what a lot of it was wow
wow yeah so what were you what kind of
what were you gambling what kind of game
uh just uh
any kind of sports online sports book
yeah okay online stuff yes okay cool
what'd the healing journey look like on
the way out of that yeah how'd you break
that
uh
well we had we had hit a pretty rough
patch in our marriage we had some um
disagreements some arguments
and
when we got married we
joined our our finances together and
when i realized
the first couple of consolidated loans
that hit our bank account i was not
comfortable so i withdrew an
understatement you were the like queen
of understatement
there were some nights i looked at him
and was just like
so
so i took the high road and i took
my money out of the bank account and
opened my own bank account opened up the
kids bank account and
um
i still continue to see
no change i was still uncomfortable with
where things were going and so i reached
out to my sister-in-law
and
we
tossed her
yes his well his brother's wife oh okay
and um
and we
finally opened up to his parents his
parents had no idea what was going on we
both kept it very hidden because we were
a little ashamed sure
and so we basically had a little
intervention for him and i just let out
everything that i was worried about and
they were kind of our
our go-betweens and so
they they really from the
the second that they knew everything
they were our support system and they
were our gods and how long ago was that
march 21st 2020
so your is your that's your that's your
dry date two years sober yes way to go
bro hey
congratulations man proud of you thank
you i'm proud of him too incredible i
wish you could see the way she's looking
at you
yeah it's so oogy it's making me
uncomfortable
she likes you a lot
incredible
so the uh
yeah that you so your family and your
wife come at you
and you just said okay they're right yep
i mean time to change yeah prior to that
you've been kind of uh ducking and
shucking and jiving and hiding and
am i right
that's a normal pattern anyway yeah yep
yeah
yeah so america in case you didn't know
the fastest growing addiction in america
today
is online porn the second fastest
growing addiction in america today is
online gambling
it's tough and it's those two things are
destroying more families than all drug
addiction and alcohol addiction put
together
and it the people don't understand the
numbers
this is one of the evils of the internet
the internet's not evil in and of itself
but uh gambling has
exploded
and i can't tell you the number of times
one of our coaches is dealing with
someone who's trying to get out of debt
on one hand but on the other hand
they're really struggling particularly
sportsbook sportsbook is a big one
and so what you did what you had there
was not unusual i'm so proud of you man
that took a lot of strength so andrew
often people roll out of an addiction
and i don't say they trade addictions
but they lean into healthier behaviors
and it sounds like your healthier
behavior was hey let's let's let's get
on a path to help us get control back
right
and so tell us about that
yeah um that night i mean like she said
we you know we all met and um
had a long talk and that night i you
know i worked third shift at the time
and i was you know scrolling through
there and came across dave ramsey and uh
i'd heard the name before
uh but it never really listened to
anything and i started listening at
night and got hooked and like everything
you were saying was you know slapping me
usually when people say you got hooked
it's a good thing i'm not sure when you
say that i like you
but that was his healthy i'm kidding i'm
kidding with you
he did he came home from work and i
was barely awake and he said hey we're
going to do this this is what we're
doing and i was like wow who
what what i'm sleep here i was like okay
we're okay sounds good so you were game
on then oh yeah and that gave you
something to focus on while you were
while you're moving those stuff now did
you go to like ga
no i didn't okay you see a coach a
counselor or anything nope i just just
said i'm stopping yeah well it made it a
little easier that was the start of the
pandemic and there were no sports going
on so that's helpful
that's how the supply dried up yeah a
little easier
well there you go that's that's true i
hadn't thought about that
so uh then you guys just lean in and
together you start doing the details now
how much further did you get plugged
into our stuff
um
i uh after a couple weeks of listening
to podcasts just nonstop i i bought a
couple of the books and um
and i guess it was a few months later we
did a uh
fpu class with uh with our church oh
good okay it took me a little while to
get heard on board with me
i can't believe what
yeah the the attic comes with another
scheme right yeah oh i got a plan i got
a plan right yeah it was read this book
listen to this podcast watch this on
youtube and i was like oh gosh well i i
you know what did i do yeah i got i got
her listening to rachel i was like if
you don't listen to dave you know i
think you like rachel she's you know
your age and she's funny i think you'll
you'll like her you said it old and
grumpy right not funny yeah we've got
young cute and funny or old and grumpy
hey so andrew yes you're not gambled
anymore no totally clean yes
when you're talking about it
your body folds up
with shame and guilt and today you walk
off that stage and you're going to leave
that crap right there right yes sir
you're done with it yes sir you're
announcing to everybody you're sobriety
and we're proud of you hey man i don't
want you carrying that stuff around i
could see it on you today you set it
down when you walk off that stage you're
right that that's that guy used to be
he's not anymore game yep thank you
that's fair
way to go guys thank you guys i'm so
proud of y'all we are honored to be a
little part of your huge journey you're
both very very courageous people
and uh you're you're impressive you're
heroes i mean the stuff you when you
stare that demon down and you beat it
that's a big and i honey i don't know
where they make you i don't know
you you're one of one of a million
you're a saint i mean i had except for
the underst except for the
understatement
[Laughter]
she can carry a house around with
understatement well i guess i guess i'll
just i'll just won't eat any dinner
tonight i guess i'll just go inside and
eat dirt i'll just wear the drapes well
y'all thank you
that's right that's right
i mean i had i had my weaknesses too and
mine stemmed a lot from wanting my kids
to have what i didn't have growing up so
i
i'm not
guilt-free from getting a credit card
and saying hey you want to wear that
name brand outfit okay you want to go to
this place okay let's do it so we really
had to sit down especially with our
oldest and explain you know
it's not that we won't ever i'm gonna
cut you off because we're gonna run up
against the clock here i'm gonna make
sure we get your screen in sorry so we
got all the books and everything for you
and stuff for you to give away and stuff
for you to enjoy thank you so much for
being here thank you andrew and courtney
hopkinsville kentucky madisonville
kentucky 62 thousand dollars paid off in
22 months making 85-95 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're going to get free
[Music]